TREY: GOOD EVENING THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US, I AM TREY
GOWDY, IT'S "SUNDAY NIGHT IN
AMERICA."
THERE WAS NO TSUNAMI, NO
WAVE, NOT EVEN A MAJORITY IN
SENATE, AND HOUSE IN DOUBT.
WEEK THAT BEGAN WITH HIGH
HOPES IS ENDING WITH AN
AUTOPSY.
FOR ALL OPTIMISTIC FORECASTS
PARTICULAR BE REPUBLICANS
WIN A VERY SMALL MAJORITY IN
THE HOUSE.
ACTUALLY LOSE A SEAT IN
SENATE, EVEN VICTORY IN THE
HOUSE IS NOT A GIVEN.
PERHAPS ON COLD JANUARY
MORNING 22 MONTHS AGO
REPUBLICANS WOULD HAVE
SETTLED FOR WINNING THE
HOUSE.
AFTER GEORGIA GAVE DEMOCRATS
FULL CONTROL, MAYBE YOU
WOULD HAVE SETTLED FOR A
MODEST VICTORY IN THE HOUSE,
EVEN A MODEST VICTORY WOULD
END THE BIDEN AGENDA.
PERHAP ITS WOULD HAVE MET
YOUR EXPECTATIONS TOO MONTHS
AGO BUT NOT 5 DAYS, 5 DAYS
AGO YOU WOKE UP WITH HIGH
INFLATION AND LOW CONFIDENCE
IN THE DIRECTION OF THE
NATION.
YOU WOKE UP WITH HIGH GAS
PRICES, CRIME SEEMINGLY OUT
OF CONTROL, CHAOS AT BORDER,
CHILDREN WHO LOST YEARS OF
LEARNING AND WAR IN EASTERN
EUROPE, YOU WOKE UP WITH
BIDEN'S APPROVAL NUMBERS
LOW, AND MAJORITY OF YOUR
FELLOW CITIZENS BELIEVING
THE COUNTRY ISED ON THE
WRONG TRACK.
WHY DID THE SHIP SINK?
WHY WERE EXPECTATIONS SO
HIGH AND SO WRONG?
WHY WERE WE TOLD THERE COULD
BE 54 G.O.P. SENATE SEATS AT
THE END.
TOLD THERE WOULD BE A
MASSIVE SHIFT IN THE HOUSE,
THERE WAS A CHANCE TO WIN
THE GOVERNOR SHIP IN NEW
YORK AND SENATE SEAT IN
WASHINGTON STATE.
WHERE ARE REPUBLICANS
WINNING IN OVERWHELMING WAYS
AT STATE LEFT AND LOSING IN
UNDER WHELMING WAYS AT
FEDERAL LEVEL?
REPUBLICAN HOPES DIED A SLOW
DEATH.
NOW IT IS TIME FOR THE POST
MORTUM.
FAILURE IS AN ORPHAN.
BUT YOU MUST FIND THE
PARENTS OF THIS FAILURE.
YOU MUST BE PART OF THE
SEARCH.
HINDSIGHT IS 20/20 ONLY IF
THE RIGHT PEOPLE ARE WORKING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I SUSPECT YOU ALREADY KNOW
PICKING A FIGHT WITH RON
DESANTIS ON MORNING AFTER
MIDTERM LOSSES DOES NOT GET
REPUBLICANS CLOSER TO
FIGURING OUT WHY THEY LOST.
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS
INCLUDING DESANTIS WERE
AMONG VERY FEW BRIGHT SPOTS
TUESDAY NIGHT, I SUSPECT YOU
ALREADY KNOW LESSON FROM
TUESDAY NIGHT IS NOT MORE
INTERNESSIE BATTLES, THE
COUNTRY IS DESPERATE FOR
COMPETENT,
CHARACTER LADEN LEADERSHIP.
YOU SHOULD COMMUTE KATE
THAT.
YOU CANNOT ALLOW THOSE WHO
WERE SO WRONG BEFORE THE
ELECTION TO GRADE THEIR OWN
PAPERS AFTERWARDS.
I SUSPECT YOU KNOW THAT
FAILURES IN PENNSYLVANIA AND
ARIZONA ARE NOT TO BELAYED
AT THE FEET OF A GUY FROM
BAKERSFIELD, CALIFORNIA WHO
CRISSCROSSES THE NATION FOR
TWO YEARS, TRYING TO HELP
CANDIDATES.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY
PENNSYLVANIA AND ARIZONA
WERE LOST, WE SHOULD ASK
PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE I
SUSPECT YOU ALREADY SEE
THROUGH CANDIDATES BLAMING
EVERYONE BUT THEMSELVES, A
POOR CRAFTSMAN BLAME HIS
TOOLS,
CONSERVISM IS ABOUT FAILED
RESPONSIBILITY.
ONE THING TO GET IT WRONG ON
THE FRONTS END.
THAT WAS DONE.
IT IS QUITE ANOTHER TO MISS
THE REASONS WHY AFTER THE
FACT.
TO BOTCH TO THE AUTOPSY,
YES.
HINDSIGHT IS 20/20.
BUT ONLY IF THE RIGHT PEOPLE
ARE LOOKING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
DO NOT LET THOSE WHO GOT IT
WRONG TUESDAY GRADE THEIR
OWN PAPERS.
DEMAND ANSWERS, STARTING
WITH WHY A PARTY WITH
EVERYONE CONCEIVABLE
TAILWIND IS STILL ADRIFT AT
SEA.
AND WOULD RATHER FIGHT ITS